EU employment and social affairs
ministers met in brussels on the 9th of
march they discuss how to better adapt
careers to the new working context
namely the technological evolution and
aging populations Kagawa noise tomar
mulatto so sweat disqus if our main
discussion today concentrated on the
2015 European semester the presidency
invited the minister's to address the
three priorities of the annual growth
survey investment structural reforms and
fiscal responsibilities for you and how
these priorities go inside with
employment and social policy challenges
bills tivo on to work our prioritises
cannon orderby not the episode so tell
us politics aside now mmm since the
employment situation in member states
continues to cause concern ministers
looked at the possibility of investment
coupled with structural reforms
ministers also discussed the need for
education and training the reintegration
of the long-term unemployed as well as
supporting job creation through tax and
benefit systems